it's been years since Beirut has
experienced an attack like this hamas's
political office in southern Beirut torn
apart and some of its high-profile
leaders killed an armed drone stuck two
floors of the building on Tuesday night
hamas's Deputy leader was killed
instantly along with six
others about 5:30 p.m. we heard the
sound of an explosion then another blast
followed by a third explosion a few
seconds later the smoke was Rising
heavily the explosion shook our
office arui was one of the founders of
the group's armed Wing the Kasam
brigades he had been living in Exile in
Lebanon after spending 15 years in an
Israeli jail before the war on Gaza
began on October the 7th Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu had
threatened to kill him in recent weeks
aruri has played a part in the release
of captives in
Gaza Hamas condemned his killing as a
cowardly
assassination we affirm that the
assassination by the Zionist occupation
of the great brother and National
fighting leader shik Salah Al aruri and
his brothers of the movement's
leadership and teams on the Lebanese
lands is a complete terrorist act a
violation of lebanon's sovereignty and
an expansion of Israel's hostility
against our people and Nation the
Zionist Nazi occupation is responsible
for its repercussions
Israel hasn't taken responsibility for
the attack but aru's assassination is
seen as a game changer in the region the
Lebanese government says Israel will
face repercussions while the armed group
hasbullah has also vowed to respond for
weeks here in southern Lebanon hasbullah
and Israel have exchanged fire hasbullah
has said in the past it will not leave
an attack on Lebanese soil without a
response and the question now is will
this low intensity battle here at the
border spill into an allout War alih
Hashim Al jaaz nakura Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer